hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcasts on
Monday [ __ ] June 27th Jill what up
what happened to this month my goodness
where's it going you know what I think
July 18th that's my July 18th
I think we'll be wrapped we'll be done
with the writing of the ten episodes of
f is for family then all we got to do is
look at the drawings and edit them for
the next [ __ ] ten months but the
heavy lifting will be out of the way
you guys like to know on an animated
show works well you sit in a room and
you come up with [ __ ] whatever yeah
you figure out how the whole seasons
going to go then you [ __ ] write it
and then it changes like 50 [ __ ]
times you rewrite you rewrite you
rewrite your record you write more you
do table reads you do all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] then once you get all of that done
what starts coming in is the animatics
which is basically the rough drawings of
the ship you know that you recorded and
then you say uh you know why is he
standing next to that chair he should be
over in the kitchen you got to do all of
that [ __ ] he's not moving enough have
him take his glasses off there or have
them [ __ ] but you got to do all of
that and then they [ __ ] draw it and
then you look at it and then it still
might not be funny and then you got to
be like I is what we wrote not funny or
is the way it's executed here not flying
that that's why it takes so [ __ ] long
in case you're wondering did you like
well [ __ ] you record it I mean you wrote
them why don't they just take out some
magic mocking and [ __ ] put them on a
piece of paper and then somebody stands
there and they flip through it like they
used to in the old days so they used to
do they'd have somebody the village
idiot go up on stage with a giant
[ __ ] notebook and he said they're
gone
just going through the thing when people
would sit there and they enjoy it and
the guy screwed up they shot him because
everybody had guns Becton least that's
the way I was in America
speaking of America what's going on in
Ireland I decided I was going to start
looking to see what the [ __ ] is going on
in these countries I'm going to be going
to evidently mano Neil Martin O'Neill
the Republic of Ireland Martin O'Neill
there there Bill Belichick he's [ __ ]
pissed because Ireland just lost the
French in some game where you're not
allowed to pick the ball up with the
hands for whatever [ __ ] reason you
know you figure if you only allowed to
use your feet or your hand so let's say
you use your [ __ ] hands I mean
there's no style of fighting where you
just use your feet right maybe Taekwondo
but David you know if you [ __ ] come
at them they're still going to punch you
in the nose right I just don't
understand it [ __ ] with you it's
actually it's a beautiful game I wanted
to get my head [ __ ] shaved the other
day right now went into this barbershop
a real barbershop when were you walk in
and there's [ __ ] men in there right
rubbing their hairy chests don't kid
there's men in there and you just
[ __ ] go whether you sit down and fill
it's your [ __ ] turn unlike these
[ __ ] goddamn hipster [ __ ] thinks
whether they got the little [ __ ] what
we call that barbershop little swivel
thing that goes around to me that says I
can just walk in right and then you walk
in yakking there's nobody here can you
shake my head Oh through those an
appointment dude look at me how long is
it going to [ __ ] take you don't to
make an extra [ __ ] twenty bucks huh
get out I go [ __ ] yourself yeah you
[ __ ] 28 President of the United
States [ __ ] haircut who is that by
the way who is the 28th president nobody
ever talks about the 28th president
let's look it up let's look it up 28th
President got by if I had to guess I'm
going to say Grover Cleveland 28th
President Calvin Coolidge the [ __ ] ah ah
ha ah the chant himself Woodrow Wilson
Woodrow Wilson who signed the [ __ ]
Federal Reserve Act
and we're all still paying for it today
you know it's a good one to look up
Woodrow Wilson's letter of regret what a
[ __ ] odds I would have said that
every down this conspiracy theory
Woodrow Wilson letter of regret all
right where is it where did Wilson look
did Woodrow Wilson regret handing
America to the Federal Reserve Woodrow
Wilson after creating a Federal Reserve
said okay here we go
I've unwittingly ruined my country I
don't know how to pronounce that word so
maybe he didn't all right just what I
wrote I am a most unhappy man I am
unwittingly unwittingly ruined my
country a great industrial nation is
controlled by its system of credit our
system of credit is concentrated see
they always got to write it so
sophisticated assist sophisticatedly I
can't understand what the [ __ ] they're
talking about like that ding
Dwight D Eisenhower when he gives that
speech about the industrial military
complex I watched that over and over
again I have no [ __ ] idea what he's
talking about even it's explained to me
before I watched the speech and by the
end of it I I don't understand it and I
feel like he said it that way either
because he was so [ __ ] smart
he couldn't relate to the common man
which I don't understand because he had
all those soldiers or he said it that
way because he had to say the way that
he wouldn't get off right I don't [ __ ]
it up
anyway said the growth of the nation
therefore and all our activities are in
the hands of a few men this is a
president a former president wrote this
ok so I don't hear any guys saying all
conspiracy theory go [ __ ] yourself it's
just like when I told you that the NBA
was fixed and then there was the
mobbed-up ref and you guys all tried to
wiggle out of it and what did they say
uh yeah there was just one of them oh
yeah what's this it was just one of them
all right we have to come to we have
come to be one of the worst ruled one of
the most completely controlled and
dominated government governments in the
civilized world lone longer a government
by free opinion no longer a government
by conviction and
the vote of the majority but a
government by the opinion and duress of
a small group of dominant men well there
you go he still didn't quite [ __ ] say
what he did Jesus Christ oh god they got
they got [ __ ] you know what they did
Woodrow they put woody from chairs their
version of chairs their version of woody
from [ __ ] chairs they put him in the
office what am I even talking about
right now I don't want to talk about
this I was talking about soccer how the
[ __ ] do I go from soccer to that so
anyways it's Martin O'Neill why would
not [ __ ] with someone an Irish brogue
and those [ __ ] glasses you know you
know just somehow et chop you to the
throat he said they got the shortened
short straw when they played France for
whatever [ __ ] reason I never even
finished the story so I wanted to get my
[ __ ] head shape and they had that
European champion was a championship was
on the highlights all [ __ ] everybody
in there was into the game so I
automatically got into it so hope you
guys know I'm just [ __ ] with you when
it comes to that it's just that when the
world loves something is a comedian it's
just so easy to make fun of it and to
get the feedback that you want which is
totally people losing their minds typing
at you in all capital letters it's just
fun um so anyways for some reason France
got an extra three days to rest their
tired legs in their swollen feet before
they got to play the little footy game
again and Ireland didn't like it you
know it's funny the guy the guy like
trashes him and says you know we got
[ __ ] over three days in an incredible
amount of time one side could have as an
advantage over another blah blah blah
blah blah that said French friends are a
really really fine team and good luck to
them in the tournament I love it [ __ ]
after you [ __ ] trash him it was
completely unfair
go [ __ ] yourself and I haven't said that
out you got a hell of a team there who
each equals good sucky yeah sneaky all
right Irish news headlines what's going
on and I'll race Foster Britain
co-signed to margins by the stupid party
I know what that means Mary Robinson is
that's not a real name
mary robinson zen an alias brexit could
have a domino effect what the [ __ ] is
breakfast isn't this [ __ ] Trump got in
trouble for that's what I loved about
Trump this week when he [ __ ] went to
Scotland and he goes yeah just like
Scotland we're going to take our country
back because I guess Scotland was voting
about whether they still wanted to be a
part of the European Union and Scotland
overwhelmingly agreed to stay part of it
evidently I don't know and Trump went
there and didn't know it and I was
reading like what everyone was saying
and it was you know trashing Donald
Trump and it was so similar to what
people write to me every week John
Salley isn't dead you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
said the wrong name I didn't mean John
Salley you know what do you what he went
for me all right
former president president of what Mary
Robinson she was president of Ireland
you know what she's a lovely lady
I vote for her what if when the [ __ ] was
she president former President Mary
Robinson has said that young people in
the UK must feel very let down by the
outcome of the brexit brexit modal
referendum and she appealed to the EU to
remember its core values what other big
[ __ ] did she say Jesus Christ can you
help out her an American here what the
[ __ ] going on over there and that
Christ it's a simple should I have to
know when I go over there some sort of
referendum should the United Kingdom
remain a member of the European Union or
leave the European Union what's going on
with the European Union the EU what
happens you guys formed a super group
but now all the egos are getting in the
way what happened huh Greece's [ __ ]
economy went down and all of a sudden
it's [ __ ] with you guys you never do
that never join a [ __ ] group take it
from a complete loner who does stand-up
right you don't join a group you know
what I mean you use a group okay what do
you guys do well yeah you cater parties
all right I'm having a party I don't
want to join your party operation I'd
like you to come over here and tie some
balloons to
some [ __ ] lamppost could you do that
and how much would that cost and here's
your check and get out of my life that's
how you do it why the [ __ ] would you
glaze it's actually amazing that they
got it done you don't I mean considering
all the [ __ ] wars they've had over
the years you know fascism communism
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] we're called
not what the [ __ ] we are how the [ __ ]
did they do all that why did they do all
that that just all comes down to bankers
what was wrong with having the pound and
then the [ __ ] Ireland had the
shillelagh right what they haven't
Sweden I know it looks like they had
some sort of thing Alouettes that design
with a little shrinker
I don't [ __ ] know I don't understand
why everybody has to get in bed with
everybody else it's going to be better
it's going to create more jobs no it
isn't no it's just going to make the
people at the top make more [ __ ]
money it's just like you know can we
have more people to [ __ ] in the ass can
we have some of your people wonderful we
what if we combined all the people right
we [ __ ] microchip them we face out
[ __ ] money what if we did that right
and now everything's on your little
microchip here right people get mugged
in the future it's going to be [ __ ]
hilarious
it's going to be some [ __ ] nerdy kid
getting dragged in by a football player
you're going to grab a bunch of dr.
peppers and some [ __ ] zagnut bars and
they're going to grab the Nerds wrist
and [ __ ] just keep swiping it making
a pay for all this [ __ ] right if you're
[ __ ] rich you're going to you can't
even go out of the [ __ ] house so
we're going to grab you and take you to
a Lexus dealership simple [ __ ] its
grab the guy just [ __ ] just start
scanning them that'd be great you know
it's not going to happen they're gonna
have doing have like 50 mil my god this
is good there's going to be some [ __ ]
going down if you get if you can have a
microchip in your [ __ ] body that has
every [ __ ] cent you ever earned that
you didn't blow on [ __ ] blood lights
and hookers you know doesn't that make
you like what's going to stop somebody
from just coming up and just sucker
punching you and then
carving your [ __ ] microchip out of
your arm right and then it's like they
got an extra life and then they just
have this [ __ ] thing and they just
start running around with tweezers just
scan in a bunch of [ __ ] why wouldn't
they just you know what they're gonna do
they'll [ __ ] chop your arm off right
and then [ __ ] hide your body okay you
know like how they used to do that like
allegedly the the Westies they chop some
guy's arm off and then they would go
around committing murders and then
they'd take the arm out of the fridge
and they'd put the fingerprints on the
gun and they'd just put the arm back in
the fridge it's if you get past the
[ __ ] humanity you know it's really
brilliant and slash borderline [ __ ]
hilarious
man I bet those guys could tell a story
Jesus Christ you know the [ __ ] they did
horrible [ __ ] but Jesus yeah to be a
funny bastard on some [ __ ] level I
know you're out of your mind but there
is something [ __ ] hilarious about
that you know and then the cops but you
know when they were drinking the cops
are just like this [ __ ] guy struck
again
you know they will laugh we go dude you
realize we're inventing a serial killer
and they'd all be sitting there laughing
their balls off and at some point the
laughter would die down is that they
then realize like wait a minute we're
kind of serial killers well we're all
doing it it's a group effort you know
it's not like it's one person so yeah
you know whatever order another Jameson
anyways I have no [ __ ] idea what I'm
talking about I have no idea what's
going on in the world and I evidently I
need to learn it I need to learn it
before you know I go to Scotland they
start handing up [ __ ] those signs you
know Trump is a [ __ ] I just all of that
[ __ ]
Donald Trump is [ __ ] he's back to
being [ __ ] hilarious again to me
because I know he's not going to win
he's not going to win the whole world
can [ __ ] relax
everybody knows Hillary's getting it
okay and what's funny is everybody's
going to reel at relax like oh thank god
we dodged that [ __ ] bullet like
Hillary isn't a [ __ ] bankers wet
dream coming down like a [ __ ] freight
train
now Jesus she better not get elected I'm
ready [ __ ] on it he wanted times I've
trashed her oh my god oh god that
[ __ ] some of the [ __ ] I want to say I
can't [ __ ] say it because in this day
and age you just you just cannot say
that you understand why a certain person
did what he did I'm a Jesus Christ is
coming home to that [ __ ] air-raid
siren
every [ __ ] can you at least [ __ ]
you know doll yourself up a little bit
Jesus Christ with the [ __ ] the
Paperchase look over here and what was
the guy supposed to do I'm just kidding
Bill Clinton would [ __ ] a hole in a tree
and he would do it with his [ __ ]
pants down with the [ __ ] Secret
Service standing with their backs to him
like 5 feet away they could literally
spin to feel the wind of his hips as he
was pumping the tree guys an animal
day in and [ __ ] day out that guy is a
[ __ ] animal God know what god bless
him god bless him you know it's just how
he's wired do you guys ever see that
episode of cheaters remember that show
they'd catch people cheating right and
that lady caught the [ __ ] can anybody
find this clip for me this Liz Lane a
southern belle she catches her [ __ ]
redneck guy stepping out on her right
and this [ __ ] guy she you know he was
supposed to be embarrassed but he was
hammered she's like oh my god if I can
face his [ __ ] I could she do this you
know slap and I had a [ __ ] chick do
this and he goes well honey did it ever
dawn on you but maybe just maybe I was
tired of [ __ ] you and I wanted to
[ __ ] someone else and he said it the
wisdom of that epic line was just it was
like he was saying like like hello
you know [ __ ] get you [ __ ] together
the [ __ ] answers right here like he
said it with such he was putting it on
her it was one of the one of the one of
the more amazing
things I've seen a human being do in
that situation you know what I mean
anyways let me get back to the [ __ ]
what's going on here in Scotland what's
going on here oh by the way so Belgium
has been added Germany has been added
even though you know I'm making I think
they're paying me like with a couple of
Stein's of beer which I don't give a
[ __ ] I just want to go over there I want
it I'm that close you know I'm going to
do Germany some weird [ __ ] town I
never heard of and then I'm driving over
to Belgium and I'm not doing what the
father [ __ ] capital of Brussels
I'll [ __ ] it with him no it is Brussels
right of Belgium Brussels right so I'm
doing like 20 things here I just
realized I never found out who the [ __ ]
marry Rob's were Jesus Christ she must
have been a great she looks honest as
the [ __ ] days long mani robin said
for president would tell you she's cute
as a button but i okay i wouldn't want
to cross her that [ __ ] shed any field
so what you guys said over there what
the [ __ ] is a shillelagh bill you don't
know all right Mary Robinson Mary Mary
Mary oh Jesus that's an unfortunate
[ __ ] picture Jesus Christ has she
ever used conditioner in our life her
[ __ ] hair looks like the Hollywood
Hills right before they catch on did the
Santa Ana winds come out of her [ __ ]
hairdryer I thought she was dead she's
not dead is she in office from 1969 to
1989 she's 72 years old she's got three
kids away I'm going to win it
Mary Theresa thank you have a vision I
hate it boring at 25 May 1945 he didn't
have a q8j machine took I don't have
time to read all this presidency alright
open the [ __ ] linckia [ __ ] Robinson
was inaugurated as the seventh President
of Ireland under Wow am I [ __ ] dumb
along do you stay in office seven
president since caveman date she proved
a remark of
we popular president earning the praise
of Brian Lenihan himself well [ __ ] if
Brian says it well then [ __ ] you before
his death five years later sorry Brian
in the Linehan film said that she was a
better president than he ever could have
been
that was a guy they went after yet had
elected [ __ ] heart
alright I'm sorry she was great that was
every [ __ ] accent over that case she
took an office yet and a reputation as
being little more than a retirement
position for a prominent politician and
breathed new life into the role and how
is that a retirement position your
President of Ireland oh good I got some
questions when I get over there
Ryan [ __ ] Linehan let's see what
Brian Lenihan look like you should get
old if you really want to see what
people look like to figure out why they
died Brian Lenihan Brian Lenihan let's
see what it looks like let's see do give
me you [ __ ] in shape [ __ ] come on man
you supposed to have the heart attack
face oh that's not the guy Cleo did you
just fart listen well no second what the
[ __ ] is what the [ __ ] is the guy's name
yeah Brian in a hen he died five years
actually the guy just looked up with
from Canada like I still have a chance
here that this guy was uh oh my god
do I have to hit [ __ ] pause to find
this again alright presidency Brian
Lenihan all right there it is Brian
Lenihan come on you [ __ ]
Ireland heritage hordeum bird eh eh okay
there we go
let's see what this [ __ ] dead son of
a [ __ ] oh there it is oh yeah that's a
heart-attack face if I ever saw I'm
saying heart attack I'm going heart
attack he died on my birthday was an
Irish and a barrister what the [ __ ] is
that I mean he sings like tens bar
ah death just get the death died okay
died down ah God to spend enough your
disease come on I say heart attack heart
attack nice and quick
pancreatic cancer 52 [ __ ] dumpster 48
Jesus Christ don't scare off this
[ __ ] subject um my condolences to the
Linehan family anyways such a [ __ ]
it's the [ __ ] worst I got a buddy of
mine is is something too I want to be
doing a benefit coming up I just have to
figure out how to put it together I got
a really good friend of mine whose wife
just got cancer for the second time and
they're getting [ __ ] buried in bills
so I'm gonna put together a show out
here in LA and you know all the proceeds
are going to go to that and that's
[ __ ] suck alright I'm sorry I thought
this would be something alright ex
[ __ ] funny right you just stand in
the a bill you want another reg you know
actually claw and just whenever you drop
dead people laugh at first because they
think you're [ __ ] around like wow man
he really committed to that [ __ ]
faceplant
well alright Nelson you just laying them
I'm sorry
Oh last week you know I recommend that
you guys go to the all things comedy
website you know for all these great
podcasts and videos and all the [ __ ] so
of course these [ __ ] Millennials they
get there and they just stare at their
[ __ ] overwhelmed - like who could you
least tell me a couple of podcasts did
you like well maybe I can look at
because I can't do anything myself
alright last week Ari Shaffir from the
skeptic tank podcast did a podcast with
comedian I'm going to butcher this name
hormoz Rashidi that's how I'm saying it
about the Middle East it's hilarious and
informative
this dude was born in Iran so rather
than listening to Bill O'Reilly talk
about the Middle East even though he's
never [ __ ] been there or [ __ ] wolf
[ __ ] Flint all these talking heads
with their books you know in their lines
of soot right
from the Bill O'Reilly collection from
the this is a Wolf Blitzer tie right
whatever the [ __ ] it is that they do to
get 2x they're extra [ __ ] money you
know who think has a better walk-in
closet Bill O'Reilly a Wolf Blitzer you
know bill did [ __ ] shiny loafers you
know set just so you know all this suits
all lined up the pocket squares and all
of that [ __ ] you know enemy you [ __ ]
take you downstairs to the wine cellar
and show you these bottles of wined and
[ __ ] hundreds of years old
you see them look at that look at that I
get this for lying every day on
television and then amazing come on you
do coke Iman do some coke all right just
that without it I just pick and I'd ask
you know the wife stuff wife's got a
rule no coke on the [ __ ] main floor
anyways I'll speaking of my wife because
I wife it's a rough one you know I got
this new thing that I'm into man and you
think it would be a big deal I like I
like [ __ ] tennis and golf shirts
I like they're comfortable they're
breathable it's a college shirt people
leggy into restaurants when you wear
them and she [ __ ] hates them I like
the Izod tennis wear so today I'm
walking out the house to go meet a buddy
of mine and I got one of those on and I
got these [ __ ] I got these
Phil Mickelson shorts whatever the [ __ ]
they are just they're just black shorts
or whatever who has some walking out a
guide me I'll seal it she goes right
because till Tiger Woods they said
what's up she [ __ ] hates all white
dress and this is one of these things
where you know as much as you want to
remain your own person when you're in a
relationship when you the person you're
[ __ ] says you're not you don't look
good it affects you but there's some I
have this is how comfortable these
[ __ ] shirts are I don't think I give
a [ __ ] I think for the first time ever I
don't care that my wife doesn't approve
of what the [ __ ] I'm wearing they had
that [ __ ]
you never have to iron them they're
great they're [ __ ] great so I was I
was at the mall there
I really should [ __ ] this is just
like free advertising for all these
[ __ ] people
what's the [ __ ] that the honor roll
student wears what's it called body
armor
yeah we're not taking that [ __ ] in our
house clothes whatever over-the-top
[ __ ] sports thing armor wear
underarms whatever the [ __ ] it is you
know what it is defense shields some
[ __ ] space odyssey' [ __ ] you know the
[ __ ] thing the thing that Steph Curry
wish it's an underarm Under Armor that's
what it is underarms do rental Under
Armor right they got some [ __ ] they
got some great clothes so I knew I knew
she didn't like that [ __ ] as I said to
us for my birthday I go I don't I don't
[ __ ] easy no I would love though the
seventh the summer's here and the time
is right for we're in some golf club so
I told it that you know I told this give
me a couple of those shirts and pairs of
shorts and I'll be fine I'll be good
she's like I usually she's such into
fashion she gets excited when I tell her
the quote and you know my [ __ ]
birthday comes along and I got to tell
you there was not a hint of any of that
[ __ ] so I called her on it like a couple
days ago I said hey you know uh I
noticed you know I asked you for those
things then not expensive you were right
there and it was an easy it was an easy
gift to get me to pad you know make it
look like you actually spent time
shopping you know just why I always go
and I get a list of workout clothes
that's always an extra fee ago right
there friend you give a couple more it
looks like you give a [ __ ] you know more
than you I'm not saying you don't give a
[ __ ] but who the [ __ ] wants to shop
nobody all right I don't want to do it
therefore nobody wants to do it that's
how that's my worldview okay I'm really
starting to learn from trunk if I feel
something then everybody else also feels
it and if they don't then we should ram
it down their throats it's somewhere and
there we take
coach is now how much have you ever seen
a guy like less tough in your life talk
so [ __ ] tough like I don't know I
don't understand like he's mistaking
having money with actually being
physically intimidating that stupid
scowl on his face
no it's like gene Simmons had a brother
that didn't make it that wasn't in a
band that's what he looks like he looks
like he's related to gene Simmons and he
resents genes success anyways plow ahead
here so my wife [ __ ] hates this [ __ ]
I called her on I was just going like
you didn't like that stuff did you she
just [ __ ] started smiling looking
down at her food and I was over there
today and I I was going to stop and go
in and buy some and I didn't and the
only reason why I didn't is because it's
Sunday and it's a mall and that's just
like I don't know I don't know what it
is I don't know what it is about the
weekends and malls my I understand kids
go in there teenagers going there
because then you run into other
teenagers and you [ __ ] go again you
go out with me right you do that [ __ ] at
least that's what we did when we of that
age but like parents I got I still
understand what why would you go there
especially if you get like some little
kid and you got to [ __ ] push him
around that goddamn stroller trying to
weave in and out of all those people I
just can't imagine the [ __ ] misery of
that you know that's definitely a wife
idea you know we should go to mall today
you know I have all these theories as to
why men die before women and you know
what it is women have to include you in
their shitty day
you know I [ __ ] there's my
sister-in-law's birthday this weekend
right so we ended up going to a to a
movie I was all excited we saw what do
we see we saw Independence Day
it was actually so bad it was good we
actually ended up having a great time
and I don't want to ruin the movie but
like the fact that the white guide
president has to come back you know and
get [ __ ] done is a little [ __ ] you
know Hollywood tries to be liberal you
know they'll have a chick president
they'll have a black guy flying a
[ __ ] jet and all that type of [ __ ]
but at the end of the day they bring
back the old founding father to come in
and save the day anyway so I had a great
time doing that right so the next night
you know my wife's going to go meet some
friends I think was actually was a
continuation the birthday celebration
and I was actually tired so I wasn't
going to go so I was just like you know
what I'm going to hang in I have a ton
of [ __ ] to do because you know I sit in
the writers room all [ __ ] day she
goes fine Co I'm like great this is
perfect I'll get a bunch of [ __ ] done
and blah blah blah blah blah and all
that type of stuff so right around the
time it's time for her to go right and
I'm about ready to have a beer or
anything and she just goes can you try
me over she didn't say it like that but
that's what she probably says honey can
you drive me over but like because I
didn't want to do it that's what it
sounded like and I was just like you
can't what why don't you drive yourself
over and she's just like me and me and
so I go full [ __ ] over she's like
what I want you to take me you know and
I just went like why can't you know I'm
home why do you got a dream you're the
one who's going across [ __ ] town
you're going across town why do I got to
go across town to you know why
you [ __ ] know why at the end of the
[ __ ] day if they have a something
shitty to do they can't do a can't
[ __ ] do it on their own somehow you
got to be that's like when they have a
[ __ ] kid now they drag the husband in
there what the [ __ ] is he doing in there
what the [ __ ] is he doing in there he's
not a doctor you know I know a guy went
in there
[ __ ] saw what was going on he passed
out now they got to patience the [ __ ] is
that you know well if I have to go
through the England in a minute well
[ __ ] talk to God
talk to God for once for once for once
the [ __ ] ran yo way and now I got to go
in there too so you can hold my [ __ ]
in and break my goddamn finger that's
[ __ ] that is the fact that [ __ ]
men gave in to that [ __ ] that you got to
[ __ ] be in there is that if you were
getting [ __ ] gallbladder surgery
would I be standing in there holding
your [ __ ] hand I don't know but I
guess if [ __ ] them gave them gall
bladders I'd stand up that gall bladder
kidney stones or some [ __ ] I guess you'd
have to be that's the dumbest [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] it's the stupidest [ __ ] ever
my wife is talking we have a kid you got
to go in there's like no she got so
[ __ ] mad at me over a hypothetical
child you know if I was smarter I just
would have said I'm getting smarter
though if I was smarter smart married
guys go absolutely i laughter without
diving is the elegant way to put the
baby in me I would [ __ ] [ __ ] it out
my ass do anything for you sweetheart
right Oh get heated here right I'm
getting smarter though as a married man
because I'll tell you this right now the
other one we went to go see the movie I
got there first okay and I got there it
was seven o'clock so I got there but
like 6:30 I was like [ __ ] you know I get
time maybe I'll you knows a place to get
a sandwich and I want to eat movie food
so I got a wrap and then they [ __ ]
had a beer too and by the way every
[ __ ] time I order this beer from
Mexico it [ __ ] sucks I'm not saying
all their beer stinks but I got to tell
you oh let me tell you that [ __ ]
[ __ ] stinks I'm going to get you the
name of this right [ __ ] Scooby a
reverse commercial there it is
the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] called Modelo
hang on a second I think that's what's
called it is the [ __ ] most bitter
hoppy [ __ ] it's like a job trying to
get the thing down but it was still a
beer so that the other day it's not all
bad so I'm sipping this beer I'm having
this sandwich I got plenty of time to
eat it a [ __ ] relaxed my wife the
lovely me is she texts me she goes hey
I'm almost there and I am like a dope I
started to text hey I'm already here I
mean I'm having a sandwich in a beer
okay now this is the deal
for all you youngsters out there one of
the things women hate the most is when
their guy is having fun without them all
right so any [ __ ] time you're having
a good time and they're not there you
got a how's it gone I know it's kind of
crowded but you always say it sucks okay
you're having a good time then you have
to [ __ ] deal with that [ __ ] right
there's a thing my wife is cool as it
gets all right I still have to go
through this [ __ ] so I almost [ __ ]
texted her I'm sitting here having a rap
enjoying a [ __ ] beer
blah blah blah blah blah and then you
know what I was like what the [ __ ] am i
doing if I say this she's gonna then say
can you get me one or she's going to
tell me to go over and go get the
[ __ ] tickets she's going to give me a
job
there's no [ __ ] way she's going to
allow me to just sit here and relax and
enjoy this sandwich in this beer that I
[ __ ] paid for I've worked all [ __ ]
day one of my [ __ ] [ __ ] so I just
erased all of it and rather than saying
all of that you know I'm on my way over
here oh I'm sitting here every sandwich
and a beer I erased all of that and I
just wrote okay
send that was it I didn't say I was
there I didn't say I wasn't there and I
sat there and I enjoyed it even though
that beer was not my favorite and then I
ended up walking over and
I ran to my sister-in-law and then I and
then like a dolt I text my wife going
yet I'm just uh you know I'm here with
your sister-in-law bla bla bla bla and
she immediately text back okay buy the
ticket immediately [ __ ] is a job for
you is a [ __ ] job you know and she
always avoiding and she's trying to
streamline our life no you're not no
you're not you're treating me like your
[ __ ] assistant 37 minutes holy [ __ ]
what am I doing here so that's one for
you okay this is what you you kiss them
you tell them you love them you're
telling that beautiful every [ __ ] day
but I tell you this okay when you having
a good time and they're not there you
never ever tell them you having a good
time no [ __ ] pictures none of that
[ __ ] because they will sit there and
they'll either chill you'll sit there
you'll be that guy you know that guy in
the fondant while everybody's having a
good time the guy in the corner was on
the phone talking to his girl why is he
talking to his girl cuz he's hollering
was having fun
stupid stupid stupid
you're [ __ ] headin again alright by
the way the Australian Austrian Grand
Prix is coming up this Sunday alright
because I'm going [ __ ] nuts right now
know who fell hockey no football it's
driving me [ __ ] crazy and the [ __ ]
goddamn Dodgers struck up some [ __ ]
deal was I don't know who I don't know
where that games are I don't know if
they [ __ ] exist anymore I can never
watch a Dodgers game sucks alright so
anyways here we go Dollar Shave Club
everybody oh jesus here we go
alright everybody shake club.com
delivers amazing razors right to your
door for a third of the price of what
the greedy razor corporations judge that
means when you join Dollar Shave Club
you can afford to shave with a fresh
blade anytime you want which feels
fantastic alright get a first class
shave whenever you use the executive
blade and that's without even hurting
your wallet and whenever you use that
you got to be sure to use dr. cabbie
the blade is gently just just gently
glides across your skin for the
smoothest shave ever shave butter isn't
your average shave cream it's a unique
conditioning formula with high quality
natural ingredients leaving your skin
feeling unbelievably soft and smooth now
is a great time to join to our shade
Club new rent members who buy a tube of
shaved butter
dr. Carver's shea butter get a month of
the executive razor for free take
advantage of this special offer today
it's available by going to
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / bar hi
dollarshaveclub.com / / alright here's a
new advertiser Fran bridge uh frame
bridge alright so they say Fram frame
bridge Cambridge is CR a.m. i'ma say
frame bridge they sell frames frame
bridge frame bridge you've got empty
walls and you've got something special
you want to frame but you never do it
because it takes two line and cost too
much money
remember when cameras weren't part of
your phone the way we take pictures has
changed but the way we frame them has it
until now please mention the following
talking points I'm going to mention
frame bridge oh now it's spelt with the
e so it is frame by frame bridge comm is
the easy way to frame the things you
love from the treasure trove of photos
on your phone to posters and artwork
frame bridge makes it easy and
affordable just go to frame bridge come
on dude and pick out the frame you want
or let their designers help you choose
you can even preview your item in any
frame / style any frame style sorry
they'll send you a pre page package to
ship your items safely or you can simply
upload a picture to frame bridge site or
app you can even upload a picture
directly from the Instagram how [ __ ]
easy is that the expert team at frame
bridge will custom frame your items in
days not weeks or months in days and
deliver your finished piece directly to
your door ready to hang in style called
frame bridge the genius site that makes
custom framing easy frame bridge offers
a happiness guarantee their team gives
each item personal care and attention
as meeting your expectation is as
important as meeting their own instead
of hundreds of dollars you'd pay that a
framing store their prices start at just
thirty nine bucks and all shipping is
free all right right now you go to frame
bridge comm fr AME bri d GE frame and
bridge frame bridge calm and use promo
code bar and you'll save an additional
fifteen percent off your first order
just go to frame bridge comm promo code
bar frame bridge comm promo code ber all
right we got two more you m PMT watches
when you're in your early 20s and 30s
money can be tight shows a lot of other
stuff that i grow still alright if
you're not careful dressing well can
quickly drain your bank account like
spending four hundred to five hundred
dollars on a department store watch why
would you do that there's some brands
out there charging insane prices for
watches that aren't even worth it well
if you want to look great without when
you go out but still have enough money
to buy him or her a drink check out
movement watches calm alright these
watches shap originally founded by two
Broke college kids i never understand
that line they had no money and then
they started a watch company with what
money what collateral so you have no
money and you start a watch company all
right movement watches cut out the
middleman in their big brand retail
markups in order to give you a stylish
wash watch for an affordable price
moving watches start at just ninety five
bucks a watch with the spark department
store quality for a fraction of the
price
there's sleek and minimalistic sorry
talking to liuyan here a modern twist on
a classic style movement has grown
organically purely by supporters like
you so join their more than 1 million
social media followers and get a
movement watch today go to m/v mt
watches that's Michael Vincent Michael
Thomas watches calm slash bar and
they'll give you fifteen percent off
your entire purchase MV MT watches calm
slash bar and lastly but not leastly
stamps calm they got the quickest and
the tightest [ __ ] coffee in the
advertising game watch how quickly this
goes trips to the post office have
become second nature to you they seem
easy because you've been doing
you're mailing and shipping that way for
so long but think about all the hassle
man dropping what you're doing driving
they're finding parking waiting there's
a much better way
stamps calm stance calm is the easy and
convenient way to get postage right from
your desk by and print official US posts
are using your own computer and printer
they make it easy to get exact postage
for any letter any package any class of
mail the instant you need it no
expensive expensive postage Mainers to
lease and no more trips to the post
office you got to try it I use it
anytime I send on my posters I'm a [ __ ]
if I can figure out so can you so sign
up for Stan's commie use my last name
bar but this special four-week trial
offer a plus $110 bonus offer that
includes postage and a digital scale do
not wait go to Stan's calm before you do
anything else click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage you type in Berg
that stamps calm and tuber
alright mercifully that's over they
advertising is who alright where the
[ __ ] is the reeds of this week ok
lab-grown food alright hey bill
wondering if you've heard of lab-grown
meat basically scientists have figured
out a way to make plants taste like meat
why is he [ __ ] with the food supply I
don't understand what they're doing this
could eliminate our need to raise and
kill millions of cows a year and help
stop the ass gas coming from these cows
from continuing to ruin our planet I'm
not sure how I feel about it but I like
the idea of it here's an example from
the article the impossible burger is
more than just peas and carrots smashed
together it's the result of some pretty
high-tech research Brown's team analyzes
meat at a molecular level
to determine what makes a burger taste
smell and cook the way it does he wants
his burger to be squishy while raw gross
then firm up and brown on the grill he
believes everything from an animal from
an animal's fat tissue to muscle cells
can be replicated using plant compounds
before starting the company Brown had a
hunch that a certain ingredient made
meat taste different than other foods I
had a strong suspicion early on that
so heme heme would be the magic
ingredient for flavor not hemp said
Brown here's a link to the whole article
would you eat this
Thanks come back to Boston oh I try not
to [ __ ] with that type of [ __ ] no I
would not eat that I want meat I eat
meat if I want ice cream I get ice cream
I don't get low-fat ice cream I don't
try to eat ice cream that doesn't make
me fat because you're going to pay the
price somehow all right and the reason
why there's so many [ __ ] cows
[ __ ] and farting into the [ __ ]
air is because there's so many people
the problem time and time again
there's too many [ __ ] people that is
the [ __ ] problem so okay we all
switch to these [ __ ] plants then what
are we going to do then we need all this
water to grow all these [ __ ] plants
we are too much of a [ __ ] burden on
the natural resources of this planet we
need to thin the [ __ ] herd that's the
deal that's it everybody if you want a
kid you have one to it the [ __ ] most
so you know you're not creating more
people than there is you right put that
work out no that wouldn't work out
because they both have to then you
created two people and we then go create
two each now keeps getting bigger one
kid right everybody has one kid two
creates one another to meet and they
create one that's the only way to
reverse [ __ ] our way out of this thing
and if you never have kids you ought to
get some sort of massive tax break I
think that that's what you should do so
then scientists don't have to sit around
and like you know well you know at some
point there's going to be no more state
consumes me to me [ __ ] people you
know I don't live on a planet with no
steak you know and I would like to go
back to just the wait cows just sort of
ran around chickens ran around then
every I don't know where he just gave me
all right different as opposed to having
miserable lives you know I don't know
anyways let's plow ahead I don't know
how I feel about the whole flight I
[ __ ] love animals and I hate when
people torture them and treat them like
[ __ ] and all that I also like eating
them I love chicken I love steaks I love
fish I like all that [ __ ] so like you
know if we could just get somebody to
get out from underneath these
corporation [ __ ] and just get everybody
on the same page
you'd be like look this is what we're
doing okay this is the problem this is
what everybody needs to do to try to at
least keep it at bay you know what
there's none of that you know what I
mean that's just this I don't it doesn't
come from the right [ __ ] people all
right getting through college [ __ ] a mr.
Burke how do I get through this college
[ __ ] I'm currently taking anatomy
physiology would in the summer since I
failed it and it [ __ ] blows ass well
why are you taking it did you ever feel
like when you were going to college you
just couldn't do it because maybe there
was that one class that was impossible
to pass if so how did you get through it
you know it's hard for me to even
imagine passing this class ever getting
it I don't know what that it I can't
even set ki any SI ology kinesiologist
Sant kinesiologist M kenderson degree
thanks by the way I saw on you Wikipedia
page that you died and I felt horrible I
know you don't care but just thought I'd
tell you well you know that's good I
guess I don't separate axis ECU um
anyways uh all right do you ever think
that you're in the wrong major or maybe
you're in the wrong school like life
shouldn't be that [ __ ] hard it's not
like you'd um if you taken these kinds
of classes I would say that the turning
point in my college career was when I
decided that I wanted to be a stand-up
comedian and I still wanted to get a
college degree for whatever reason it
was important to my parents and I don't
know I just want to be a college
graduate I don't know why so I got out
of the college that I was at and I
transferred to Emerson College which was
more of a performance school and people
made movies and it was acting radio and
all of this [ __ ]
and all of a sudden my grades went up
because I was doing [ __ ] that I was into
other but there was a couple of [ __ ]
classes
that just sucked there's always going to
be a couple of those how do you get
through you know what you do
don't blow it off because if it's
already hard you get three days behind
in that thing it's going to be like
being a month behind for you so what I
would do is I would just stay on that
[ __ ] and just be like all right
plus do this taken over the summers a
joke - it's practically impossible you
know I was so old by the time I [ __ ]
graduated college that like man
transferred to Emerson I was like I
think I was almost 23 years old and I
was still just beginning my sophomore
year I transferred there in January of
whatever year by December of the
following year I had done three years of
college I just [ __ ] I just I just
said [ __ ] this and I did I finished my
sophomore year January to April and then
in the summer I picked up a semester so
I finished that then the next year was
my junior year and then I went to summer
school again picked up another semester
and then the following fall was my
second semester my senior year and that
was it I gave it the old write day a
friend and [ __ ] out of here but what
you have to do is when you're going
straight through like that or if you're
doing like the summertime [ __ ] is you
got to stay on it just treat it like a
[ __ ] job it's actually a good
exercise it's something that sucks it's
something that you hate and you just you
know rather than running from just turn
around and face it and get through it if
this is the degree you want but
sometimes if it's that [ __ ] hard it
means that you're a square peg trying to
go into a round hole and you need to go
after what you really want to [ __ ] do
because you know when you do what you
want to do you have a passion for it and
it's easy cheap hill that was original
or whatever that that did fit that
advice fit alright
would you consider a Vegas residency
dear countrymen [ __ ] face at this point
in your career if offered would you
accept a comedy residency in Las Vegas
or would you be offended as there's
plenty of life in that old dog yet if
not how bad would you your career have
to be going before you accepted in which
hotel would you
to work in next time you come to
Australia play a gig in Adelaide I don't
know
without all backwards [ __ ] I mean I I
never thought you were take it easy you
[ __ ] would I do that why I couldn't well
if I didn't have efforts for family or
anything like that I don't think that
that's for me I I think my act would dry
up if I just stayed in the same venue
having said that the way you're the way
you're framing that gig as if it's a sad
thing that happens to comedians dude
those are multi-million dollar contracts
and anybody who's ever done one of those
as long as they didn't go to the crap
table after this show every night rides
off into the sunset like with bags and
bags of cash that's just something that
I have no interest in at this point in
my career in doing I still like
traveling and that type of stuff I do
have to tell you though if it just
wasn't in Vegas just that town does
nothing for me sitting there in the
[ __ ] desert I would go nuts but I do
have to say that you know if I could you
know all of a sudden just get off the
road I totally understand why comedians
do that after a while alright so there
you go all right
I'll tow your [ __ ] town I'll try to
get close to it next time alright okay
bill getting people you hate fired
alright this already sounds evil hey
bill love your [ __ ] I'm almost 30
mistakes are made and now I work at a
[ __ ] factory i shoveled literal [ __ ]
with a payloader for about 10 hours a
day which isn't so bad but it's made
worse by my terrible coworkers it's a
small operation everyone is about twice
my age and for the most part they are
pretty average blue-collar guys we all
hate our boss and his yes-man errand boy
about Aaron Burr
like he's the kind of guy who is always
right
done his way run and tell the boss what
the rest of us are doing rat bastard
type all right
he's also the kind of guy who says the N
word to let the rest of us know he's a
no guff taking no shits given type of
guy he's not he's white as the driven
snow and think he's Indian because he
purchased a t-shirt at Walmart and with
Wolves on it dude this is [ __ ] pretty
random so far well today I took my stand
i snitched to human resources oh you
[ __ ] rat bastard he goes I told them
how one black employee knows errand boy
a racist to you you're punks you have no
punctuation in this this is neat the
immunity hey you know I didn't like how
in the beginning you just [ __ ] played
the victim like I'm almost 30 mistakes
were made and I work at his [ __ ] factory
like you just glossed over all your
stuff and then you're saying you got
terrible coworkers or well what about
what you want about you you're [ __ ]
off a punctuation here mistakes were
made mistakes are continuing to be made
sir
alright let me try to get through I told
them how one hour one black employee
knows errand boys a racist and that he's
pissed I also told them about the weird
sexual [ __ ] he says like fisting his
girlfriend all of this is true and the
guy's a complete [ __ ] who knows the
boss won't fire him and he takes a
complete advantage of that by making our
lives hell it's just like Animal House
out is the guy's name Niedermayer anyway
I come home and smoke some weed because
that's what you do when you shovel [ __ ]
and now I'm feeling shitty myself I hate
the guy and I really hate my boss but
sure enough Human Resources called me
and I could sense their panic my money's
on their fight on they're firing him
everyone else at work wants him gone and
is hoping he gets fired but now I'm
starting to feel bad he's an [ __ ] who
I hate and I feel like I'm sticking it
to the man but that I go too far
I don't I'm not big on ratting people
out to be honest with you
was there a way that you could have gone
to him and just said hey listen not for
nothing I don't wanna listen you
dropping the n-word you know and I don't
wanna listen you talking about fisting
your girlfriend that has nothing to do
with the job okay
and then he would make your life
unbelievably and and then I would say
that's what you should have done you
should kind of in and come in all you
guys should have just approached him
right like Mickey Rourke at the end of
Pope of Greenwich Village because the
tape I took us a [ __ ] dead cop right
you just come up to and just say listen
here's the deal okay you still are
supervisor but no longer you drop in the
n-word and no longer you talking about
fisting your girlfriend around us we
don't want to hear it anymore you
understand if you do we're going to
human resources
all right a [ __ ] creepy named human
resource so [ __ ] disgusting yeah
that's what you showed them but you know
what you live in you learn this guy
sounds like a [ __ ] oh you know what I
mean
just do that in the future oh and then
you could say and by the way you could
try to get any of us fired that's going
down too so basically what we're saying
is you've lost all control to intimidate
us now but we'll still do what you say
as long as you're not a [ __ ]
all right go [ __ ] yourself run along why
don't you do that you like what I just
pitched there that's like when the cast
of friends all got together negotiated
together right they got their money you
could do that at your [ __ ] Factory
all right laying off the booze hey Billy
lunch after hearing you talk about
drying out you really inspired me to do
the same I drink entirely too much right
now after about eight days of daily
commitment I'm up to about a half a
fifth a day with the odd beer mixed in
wet he said that's about eight years of
daily commitment oh it says eight days I
thought he was like drying out and also
he's boozing that confused all right
after about eight years of daily
commitment I'm up to about half a fifth
a day and with an odd beer mixed in I
know it's a lot but I've worked out my
tolerance so much
I don't really get drunk anymore I just
lose an hour here and there no big deal
right yeah that's called blacking out
anyways I was able to quit smoking weed
after five years of heavy daily use no
problem I was even able to quit using
oxy cotton Jesus after about three years
of eating and sniffing pills all damn
day I've been able to maintain a normal
life while going through these ups and
downs I'm married with the kid and a
house and a great job if you make more
than a million dollars I probably manage
your retirement account but despite
being able to put the hard [ __ ] down
booze has been the hardest so far last
week I decided to jump off the wagon
with you it's been hard as hell but I've
been able to stick to it better than I
ever had I'm trying to limit beers to
two a day and only drink liquor on the
weekends I've slipped once but I'm doing
my [ __ ] best I don't have a question
more of a request please keep us updated
on your progress it's helping me with my
own journey because none of my friends
really drink at all
much less the way I do and my wife
doesn't even know the extent of my issue
which is an issue on its own yeah it is
makes my struggle a bit easier to hear
you having the same troubles as I have
was sticking to my resolution thanks for
giving me the kick in the ass I need to
get my [ __ ] together
alright dude this is what you need to do
alright after just saying don't text
your wife that you having a good time
you got to let you know you got to let
your wife know about this this is a
major thing you're not sitting there
eating a [ __ ] turkey wrap having a
[ __ ] bitter Mexican beer whatever the
[ __ ] it was called I would talk to her
about it because then she can she can
watch it dude I can't [ __ ] watch I
can't I can't do this for you you need
to have your wife involved in this and
just say listen I've been drinking
entirely too much and I need your help
alright so I gotta be honest we do I try
like right now I have a beer a day and
that's only because my wife had some
people over they left a bunch of beer in
the fridge and it's taken up all this
space and I don't want to dump it down
the sink you know not dump it out a
bunch of beers I just have one
day and what sucks is that Corona Lite
which are [ __ ] horrific so I don't
even enjoy them but I just have like one
a day but last night you know it was
Saturday night I'm home
you know I got the best [ __ ] bar in
town I got high-end booze and you know I
had a couple of home ports which you
know as I've mentioned before there's
the bar pour and there's the home pour
because you can lie to yourself that you
have in two scotches a night but you
know when you go out to a bar and you
see what their scotches are you like oh
wait did I say - I meant nine so yeah
like last night you know I had a couple
two three of those after having the beer
during the day and I woke up today I
felt like I got hit by a truck you know
it was awful
I walked my dog around the block and I
shook it off and I was just like like
you know what it is it nighttime it's
brutal being sober at night sucks but
being sober in the waking up the next
day stone sober is the greatest it feels
better than getting shit-faced so you
know a my wife now she stays on me she
stays on me buddy it's wit like I don't
want like you sound like you know you
you you've had some hard core luckily I
don't have like an addictive personality
my thing is I have time I have free
[ __ ] time and I get into like and I'm
a creature a habit like if I can't if I
like this is how I work like if I was to
go out and buy a [ __ ] pint of ice
cream right and I was the wolf that
[ __ ] thing down one night I would
start doing that that's what I would do
so like if I you know and all these
[ __ ] addicts to go to AAA and all I
should they always trying to make sure
they try to make like everybody's a
[ __ ] addict you know I'm not doing I
don't have like a [ __ ] bottle in the
back of my [ __ ] toilet and [ __ ]
sitting there shaking drinking [ __ ]
mouthwash and [ __ ] you know what I mean
I just like drinking I enjoy it you know
what I mean but as I get older like just
paying for it the next day is making it
not [ __ ] worth it so I just don't do
it
and whenever I decide to stop I just
stop and it sucks for a few days and
then what it is is it's not part of my
daily routine and then I literally just
forget about it you know but I don't
know you seem like a little bit beyond
that so I would definitely reach out to
you your wife and see if she can help
you in maybe she can help you stop there
and if you need more help I would go do
that but don't depend on me because I
don't have any kids and I live like a
[ __ ] 14 year old so I'm not a good
person to use
I mean having said that I'm just doing a
beard day if that helps you alright
okay STD oh Jesus STD oh Jesus all right
bill Billy what's that red mark I don't
know what that means is that something
else I need to be self conscious about
all right this is a gnarly one I
recently found out that I have HPV
aka genital warts and then he says gross
it's actually very common and it's just
a few small bumps but it [ __ ] sucks
anyways it can show up f years after
you've received it so I have no idea who
I got it from once again another great
reason to get married to stay out of
that [ __ ] world is my question I
recently met an amazing girl we have a
lot of the same interest she's a hard 10
yada yada yada point is I really like
her I'm getting treated for the HPV but
I respect her enough to tell her of the
risks she's getting into indicate in
case it goes that far so bill how do I
tell her that I have an STD and that
there's a small chance she could get it
I don't want to mess up this opportunity
but my other options are basically to
move to a cabin in the woods to six
months until this is completely gone I
thought it'd be funny to hear your
advice oh it would [ __ ] yeah you got
to tell it totally 100% teller and then
just don't just say listen so I can't do
anything for six months other than to
get to know you better
you know and this is the thing if she
doesn't want to stick around for that
hey god bless her who gives a [ __ ] you
know what I mean you got to look at it
like well what else wouldn't she stick
around for but then again you're also
coming out of the gate saying you got a
[ __ ] STD yeah you know there's no
right or wrong answer other than to not
you got to tell people that [ __ ] you
know don't you wish the person that had
it told you you don't you don't you got
it we got to break the chain there women
are so much more advanced emotionally so
much more they understand love
they understand emotions they understand
so much more than guys do and it's not
our fault it's not their fault the way
that they are and all that type of [ __ ]
it's just how we're [ __ ] wired I
don't [ __ ] understand it it is what
it is but I you know if she really likes
you when she's understanding and then
you sitting there saying you know she's
a hard ten people are trying to [ __ ] her
all the time so you're gonna be going
like listen is something embarrassing
but it's going to be cleared up in six
months and I respect you enough to tell
you you know we could hang out get to
know each other better and all that type
of stuff but you know there's no way I'm
having sex with you or anybody else
you'll come off responsible you come off
as honest and if that's what the [ __ ]
she's looking for she'll stick around if
she doesn't then [ __ ] lay low for six
months lay low for [ __ ] six months
and then you know whatever go to the gym
and get [ __ ] shredded no don't do
that you'll get more ladies coming up to
you stay away
anyways let's uh let's limit let me let
me finish off this [ __ ] podcast what
are we up to here hour and eight minutes
all right
there's anything else I wanted to talk
about Oh Oh [ __ ] Billy red face is uh
finally going to get himself a car I'm
going to order it just [ __ ] in a week
because they don't have the color that I
want and if I'm going to buy a new car
oh frugal Freddy's getting the [ __ ]
Karla that he wants and I'm not going to
tell you guys what kind of car that I'm
getting because I because I want to
enjoy the process I don't want this news
you know when fools you couldn't get
this one you go get the one you want but
I [ __ ] looked at everything I looked
at the genuine I looked at the [ __ ] I
looked at a BMW I looked at Alexis I
decided that I want one of those [ __ ]
4-door sedans that [ __ ] cruisers
I found a BMW to basically be you know I
love the German like precision of
precision how come I kids say that
precision there you go but I'll think I
can speak you know you could just sit in
and you just feel the German all of it
no wasted movements yes the suspension
is stiff she wants a comfortable ride
you get the 7 Series I looked at Alexis
I don't like that grille it looks like
Darth Vader's mouth on his [ __ ]
helmet and wow I don't know I think I
found the one though I literally looked
at everything
Mercedes BMW Jaguar Lexus the whole
[ __ ] thing you know I'm not getting a
sick ass model I'm getting the one decks
decking that has the right endless well
this is what I'm going to get a
four-door sedan that has the biggest
[ __ ] engine in it that I can get in
it right and but I'm not going to buy a
high-end car so I can still take it to
the [ __ ] grocery store and when some
[ __ ] [ __ ] opens they're doing in my
car it's not going to kill me you know
what I mean because I don't get I just
don't understand having a high-end car
like psycho high end like I'm buying a
mid-range
you know car I mean all of them seem
[ __ ] high-end to me because I've
driven a Prius for nine [ __ ] years
do you guys know I'm on my fourth car of
my life that's all I said at an 83 Ford
Ranger then I had this [ __ ] I bought a
used I bought that used I drove that for
[ __ ] 10 years and then and then it
burned down the side of the road that's
a long [ __ ] story then I bought a in
like 96 and 97
I bought a 1988 Honda Accord for two
a five-speed [ __ ] love that car and it
was the top-of-the-line Honda Accord the
DX whatever the [ __ ] it was it was
thought that was a great [ __ ] car and
then I got a then I moved back to New
York so I didn't need a car wait a
minute yeah and then I bought my Prius
and I got the f-100
that's all I've had that's pretty
[ __ ] good all right almost 50 [ __ ]
years old I've been driving since 1984
Jesus Christ I'm old I've been driving
for 32 [ __ ] years I've had basically
I've had three cars right one two three
four four gosh that's pretty [ __ ]
good nice little Freddie so I've had
enough of the Prius and I had enough of
it you know it's funny about that car
because it's a Toyota and I've changed
the oil and I've maintained it and
everything like there is a major part of
me that wants to drive that car for the
rest of my [ __ ] life because it's
hilarious to me because I know I could
get a million miles out of that car
because at the end of the day all these
[ __ ] dopes whose cars [ __ ] the bed
unless like you know member like the
BMWs a few years ago and they were just
designed to fall apart it's fifty to
sixty thousand miles you know unless
it's being done on purpose at the end of
the [ __ ] day the engine block it's
made out of [ __ ] steel like that that
thing's not supposed you know supposed
to have any problems with that that
thing in theory all of that [ __ ] should
last for [ __ ] ever I granted thing
here a thing there will come loose or
something like that but the engine
itself when people just have when your
engine is just fried the valves of fried
and all that [ __ ]
you weren't maintaining the [ __ ] car
and for the life of me now when you can
go to all of these [ __ ] places I'd
still never go to Jiffy Lube I still
take it to the dealership Jiffy Lube
because it's so getting in and out of
there I always get nervous so you always
hear those stories that you know they
drain the oil out and forget to put it
back in
basically the poltergeist you know you
move the headstones but you didn't move
the bodies it's basically the car
version of that like they take the
[ __ ] oil out and you know whoever
supposed to put it in up top doesn't do
it the guy down the bottom is he just
drains the [ __ ] oil
all right then he puts the plug back in
and he's got the [ __ ] grease gun he
lubes the chassis all up hits all the
points right like he
[ __ ] nose like he even knows what
model you have and weird where they all
are right he's just [ __ ] looking for
those plugs to fill up right and
meanwhile some other [ __ ]
four five six quarts of oil whatever it
takes in the top your engine and
sometimes they forget then you drive
away right and then well then what are
you going to do you're going to go down
there they're not going to give you if
they're going to give you the amount of
money that your car is worth which is
the total [ __ ] over right because if
it's a you know like my car I can't
imagine what my car is worth right now I
mean it has to be worth like maybe
$1,200 what the thing is is for me to
replace it to go out buy another car I
mean I can't buy a $1,200 [ __ ] car
she was saying so I was take it down to
the goddamn dealership so anyways I know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about some
weeks I got diarrhea of the mouth and
this is [ __ ] one of them that's it
for the podcast I'm still trying to
figure out a way to bring a couple of
listeners I decided that a contest isn't
the right [ __ ] way to do it I want to
have a couple of podcasts maybe a couple
two three podcast listeners come in for
the final table read of the year
provided you don't tell everybody what
happened in the script which could also
be a [ __ ] problem I think this whole
idea was stupid I think was a stupid
idea you know what [ __ ] it you know what
[ __ ] it that offers off the table I'm
sorry I just dis day and age everybody's
going to [ __ ] go I won't [ __ ] say
anything and then you know what they are
they gonna go right when what did she do
after all this yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
you're gonna go right [ __ ] down
you're going to [ __ ] me over I know
things it's too much of a risk I'll come
up with something else
all right here we go our 15 minutes
there you go you guys enjoy your Monday
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'll check in on
you on a Thursday I hope you guys have a
nice couple of days they alright see ya